he's made just one appearance but he's
got find the attention freedom party
leader have Willers at his only gig of
this campaign so far his life has been
threatened so he hardly appears in
public but his slogans have been the
same for years no migration closed
borders another lands outside the
European Union that is everything I'm
fighting for make these people comfort
again and return the Netherlands to them
and if we don't that's why it's such a
crucial and historic election that if we
don't and we will cease to exist we will
lose the Netherlands we will have no
freedom and no sovereignty anymore
demonstrators opposed to wielders warned
their fellow voters not to believe in
his rhetoric don't let him scare you is
her message but in Parliament in The
Hague will ders freedom party may be
about to become one of the strongest
fractions in a complicated political
landscape a seat here is what candidates
are fighting for but the electorate is
deeply divided left-right and the major
players are in standoff the number of
options is confusing to 28 parties are
running to be elected live on national
radio that tough candidates try to
clarify voters confusion total of nine
party leaders accepted an invitation
from the public broadcaster the election
could have a big impact on the future of
the EU but the debate focused more on
people's daily concerns the pension age
and job security
if Prime Minister Mikati wants to remain
in power he'll have to rely on several
parties to form a coalition his most
formidable opponent will ders was
missing from the radio debate and nobody
mentioned him I'm particularly fighting
to get across my message to the Dutch
public I'm discussing with as many
people as possible my vision my views on
the future of the Netherlands and
not debating was a particular colleague
right-wing populists SAR also a concern
for Remco ray of the non-voter party he
believes the freedom party gains its
strengths from Protestant to this group
he has an offer to make the seats we win
in Parliament will remain empty we
promise we will do absolutely nothing in
the next four years I'm not myself I'm
not a nun folder because I don't know
who to vote I voted the same party every
time I'm disappointed because they gave
up big points but big big missions they
had they gave up so that's the the
moment I became a nun voter the other
thing I could have done last elections
is for evils as in previous elections
Dutch voters may change their minds on
Pauling day but for now yet we'll ders
Freedom Party could well become one of
the strongest without even having taken
part in a real election campaign